bonjour jean frédéric poisson merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france gérald darmanin envers devoir
mettre en garde les catholiques de
france contre de nouvelles
manifestations qui ne respecteraient pas
les gestes barrière le préfet de police
de paris à lui interdit hier soir le
rassemblement qui était prévu tout à
leur place saint sulpice à paris
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre tout
à l'heure notamment à paris
manifestation ou pas alors ça je ne sais
pas nous verrons bien dans d'autres
endroits de de france le les préfets ont
accepté que serra cependant se déroule
ce que je pense surtout c'est que
l'interdiction du préfet de paris est
motivée par des raisons qui sont
beaucoup moins avouables et je constate
que nul ne peut imaginer que le préfet
le droit d'interdire une manifestation
parce que peut-être les gestes barrière
n'y font pas respecter ça se décide la
pure foutaise ce n'est pas du droit mais
je vois que la première raison c'est que
d'après le préfet de paris ce
rassemblement serait un rassemblement
cultuelle est en réalité si ça qui
dérange beaucoup d'autorité c'est que
dans la mesure où elles ont prononcé une
interdiction formelle de célébrer un
culte est bien l entente que cette
interdiction soit respectés y compris
dans des endroits où ce sont des
modalités qu'elle n'a pas le droit en
principe d' interdire c'est ça le
problème de fou justement début novembre
la demande des évêques il ya des
associations catholiques d'avant le
conseil d'état pourra le maintien des
messes a échoué vous parlez la liberté
de culte
quid de la liberté de culte en france
c'est tout problème
comme beaucoup d'autres libertés dans ce
moment elle est extrêmement malmené vous
vous avais parlé il ya quelques instants
dans notre journal de cette volonté des
restaurateurs et les cafetiers de faire
valoir leur droit à travailler il ya
beaucoup d'autres personnes qui ont
essayé les libraires il ya quelques
jours et plus généralement le problème
de fond c'est que on ne cesse de le dire
d'un côté
mettez un masque respecter les gestes
sanitaires et tout ira bien
et d'un autre côté nous expliquer que
dans certaines circonstances même si
vous étiez absolument déterminé à
respecter si je reste à mettre les
masques à vous laver les mains eh bien
ma foi il est probable que vous
participiez à la propagation du virus
c'est incompréhensible et vous disais
tout à l'heure dans votre journal le
premier ministre nous explique qu'il
n'est pas question de rouvrir ms mais
qu'on pourra ouvrir un magasin de jouets
alors je comprends très bien
l'étonnement qui va être celui des
cafetiers-restaurateurs celui qui sera
celui des libraires dans quelques heures
qui vont venir mais enfin est ce que le
virus se propage moindre les magasins de
jouets que dans des restaurants ou chez
des libraires
on voit bien que ça n'a aucun sens et
malheureusement la liberté de culte en
france est soumise à des restrictions
qui sont insupportables pour les
citoyens que nikon un citoyen pour tout
le monde pas simplement pour les
croyants et qui vont 13 au delà pour ne
pas dire qu'il méprise ce qui est notre
richesse à tous c'est à dire l'état de
droit je le dis et je suis d'accord avec
l'extrait que vous avez passé de
guillaume est un art tout à l'heure
vendredi soir à saint sulpice où j'étais
avec moi même j'ai parlé juste après lui
nous sommes effectivement en train de
glisser là quelque chose qui vous sont
très fortement à un état de dictature et
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
chrétiens de france parce que tous ne
manifeste pas et accepte tant bien que
mal les restrictions il ya pas une
scission entre d'un côté les
traditionalistes qui veulent à tout prix
assister aux messes malgré le contexte
sanitaire et elle est plus modérée qui
eux sont prêts à patienter
il ya une palette comme d'habitude
devient beaucoup de diversité chez tous
les croyants de france et de navarre si
d'ailleurs vous interrogiez les
musulmans ou les juifs et les croyants
des autres religions vous auriez je
pense sans doute le même le même genre
de diversité leur état d'esprit c'est
qu'ils sont attachés à leur liberté et
ça a été très bien dit par eux la jeune
fille qui s'est exprimé avant-hier que
vous avez que vous avez montré tout à
l'heure dans votre reportage la liberté
de culte pour les croyants avec une
chose qui est indissociable leur
existence c'est un élément essentiel
constitutive de notre rythme notre vie
quotidienne ça fait partie de notre
santé c'est comme ça je
comprends que ceux de mécontents parents
nos contemporains qui n'ont pas la
chance d'être croyant le comprennent mal
le saisissent pas lé séisme al
d'apporter ce que je suis en train de
dire mais pour autant c'est ainsi donc
nous sommes attachés à ça ensuite je
vois que c'est pas tant à faire de
modération à l'égard du culte comme une
question aussi de génération il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
peut-être davantage exposés que d'autres
virus et et qui peut être ont
l'intention de prendre davantage de
précautions
peu importe tout à l'heure vous disiez
que finalement on comprenait pas
vraiment la stratégie gouvernementale et
par rapport à la crise sanitaire
manifester pour la liberté de culte est
ce qu au final c'est pas un prétexte
pour dénoncer plus généralement les
restrictions liées au confinement à ce
que ce pas politique tout ça à ce n'est
pas un prétexte c'est une réalité un
prétexte ça vous à dire qu' on aurait
l'intention de se camoufler ou non
j'ai déposé comme président de via la
voix du peuple
ah ça tangue le référé ces derniers
temps devant le conseil d'état pour nous
manifester justement pour faire valoir
que ce qui est en danger c'est bien sûr
notre liberté d'assister au culte de
manière collective mais notre liberté de
circuler notre liberté nous cultiver
notre liberté sociale affective familial
ça tout ça est en jeu tout ça est en
cause
[Musique]
le problème de fond c'est bien
l'ensemble des attaques faites contre
nos libertés dont la liberté de culte
n'est qu'un aspect d'une certaine façon
alors il est extrêmement spectaculaire
il est essentiel il est fondamental il
est garanti par les textes fondamentaux
et par le droit donc c'est pour ça que
cette attaque est violente et
insupportable mais vous avez raison
c'est que ça n'est pas du tout un
prétexte c'est la continuité d'un
septembre d'action et je souhaite que
les français se mobilise de manière
massive pour faire entendre cette
liberté là comme les autres et je
souhaite que aujourd'hui ils se rendent
sur les parvis de l'église pour
dimitri cultes comme demain j'espère
qu'ils iront soutenir leurs commerçants
bill nous devons absolument faire
comprendre à ce gouvernement que la
façon dont il gère cette crise est
insupportable qu'elle ne ressemble à
rien qu'elle n'a aucun sens et on voit
bien qu'elle mena de contradictions en
contradictions et ne n'accepteront pas
de payer de nos libertés le prix de
cette incohérence et s'il arrive là
quelques alertes et déjà il ya quelques
jours sur le fait qu' il ne faudrait pas
que le gouvernement ait l'intention de
nous empêcher de nous réunir pour noël
parce que là la rage que je sens poindre
et qui s'expriment parfois dans le
peuple français pourrait prendre je
pense des proportions incontrôlables
donc faire très très attention à ça
quand on veut en bray quand on veut
tenir les français bride courte comme
dix premiers ce ne sont pas des chevaux
merci cers à 10 ans de vie culturelle et
sociale
le mot est passé le message est passé
merci jean frédéric poisson d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
du rdpc des le parti chrétien démocrate